this is a frequency dictionary it
doesn't list words alphabetically it
lists them in order of how often we use
them in American English the Dozen most
commonly used words are in order the B
and of a in two as part of a full
infinitive have two as a preposition it
I that the ranking is based on analysis
of the Corpus of Contemporary American
English a collection of 400 million
words from 150 000 books magazines
newspapers academic journals radio
broadcasts and TV shows in the back they
separate words by parts of speech we say
yes more often than no we talk about
this more than that we say million more
often than five it is more popular than
I am the most commonly named thing is
time and for all you Jokers out there
think again the 420th most used word is
death